i have to of course mention this we
today at the daily wire unveiled um our
new product which we're now getting into
the men's grooming game with jeremy's
razors uh of course the god king jeremy
boring with his own razor line now i i
will say
i'm uh
normally i would say that i'm i'm
ethically
philosophically opposed to shaving in
general as is clear from my appearance
um but even i will say that these are
high quality razors which we'll get into
the backstory of this but some of that
comes out in the in the the ad that we
put together for this
um high quality razors with a with an ad
that reflects the quality of the razors
let's
let's play that for you now
[Music]
do you remember when there were two
genders and only one and a half of them
had to shave their mustaches
oh hi i'm jeremy boring ceo and god king
of the daily wire harry's razors used to
advertise on our shows they're a great
product and we were happy to do it
that's before some peon who works for me
went and said that boys are boys and
girls or girls and that was just too
much for harry's
they condemned our views views held by
millions of americans and virtually
every human who's walked the planet
until about 15 minutes ago as
inexcusable and they dropped their ads
from our network because of what they
called values misalignment
you're damn right our values are
misaligned and it's not just harry's
either gillette razors used to be the
best a man could get
then they decided that men are too toxic
unless you're the kind of man who
teaches his daughter to shave her beard
if that makes sense to you keep buying
gillette
but if you've had enough of the woke
bull and you're tired of paying
companies like harry's and gillette to
hate you
you can buy my new razer instead
behold jeremy's razors yes they're real
yes they're fabulous
but jeremy you say you're a stealth
silver fox with a salt and pepper beard
that's the envy of lesser men
you're damn right i am
and i want to be clear that shaving with
the jeremy's razor won't actually make
you look more like me
you're giving me power
it could make you look more like this
guy though
and that's the most homoerotic moment
you'll ever get from a jeremy's razor
commercial
what kind of man shaves with a jeremy's
razor
i don't know how about cowboys
firefighters those guys have shot osama
bin laden
i mean no none of those guys have ever
even heard of a jeremy's razor but
imagine how much more manly they'd be if
they had
right now you're probably wondering if
this whole thing is a joke
sure it is that doesn't mean it isn't
real or that it won't be the best shave
of your life
harry's razors doesn't want your
business i do
they seem to hate you and i
well i can't say that i love you but i
don't mean you any specific
harm our country's in trouble
conservatives are being cancelled by
hollywood the media universities and now
harry's razors stop giving your money to
woke corporations who don't think you
deserve their product
give it to me instead
head over to ihateharris.com and
pre-order your founders series razor and
shaving cream set today
[Music]
yeah i have to say um uh it's a great ad
i am very upset that we had a
flamethrower here at the office
apparently and i was not given a chance
to play with it at all but i guess you
know safety concerns um i love the whole
ad i thought
my favorite part was if i had and i'm
and i'm just not playing favorites at
all not not biased at all but um
we did get a glimpse of the best-selling
most acclaimed lgbt children's book of
all time which you can get at
johnnywalrus.com so that was a great
moment as well
um
but this is we have to keep in mind as
it says in the ad
harry's
you know we had been advertising with
them
they decided to pull all their ads
not even because there was some
coordinated campaign where they were
getting all kinds of pressure from all
over the place but as is so often the
case
it's a small minority of people and in
this case now we've seen small
minorities
um imposing their will on major
corporations we've seen that at business
we're seeing it right now at disney
we've seen it at netflix we've seen in
many places in this case it was one
anonymous twitter account with two
followers
who nobody is paying attention to nobody
cares and all they did was just send a
tweet out to harry's saying uh as you
know michael knowles thinks that
uh you know men are men and women are
women that's that's all that knowledge
really said
and just because of that harry said well
okay we'll pull all our advertisements
this is a profitable arrangement for for
harry's just because of that one
person that you want to talk about
privilege that's the privilege you have
that is the ideal so much of the
privilege in this country is
ideologically
defined
and that's the privilege you have as a
leftist
conservatives don't have that kind of
privilege because the left runs all the
institutions and they make all the
products
and that's why
you know the razors here it's it's a
like so much of what we do it's a it's a
joke because it's funny and it's a troll
and we um we put a lot of effort into
very elaborate trolling at this company
which is one of the reasons why i like
working here and i appreciate it as a as
a troll you know at heart myself but
it's also a lot of being a joke it's
also a very so also very serious thing
which is that
you know when this happens we've gotten
used to this with companies
where they
they announce
that's what harry's did it wasn't just
they pulled the ads
they
announced that uh they don't want
anything to do with us
we're bigots we're this and that where
we have inexcusable values which is an
attack not just on us but obviously on
all of
everybody in the audience
because what they're implicitly saying
is well what all you people
and why do you why are you still
watching and listening
to all this bigoted material with these
in excuse you must have the inexcusable
values too so we have these companies
that they come out and and announce like
we don't want your business we hate you
we we oppose everything that you stand
for
on a real fundamental level too
and usually what happens is they
companies do this
and then we on the right we complain
about it and we whine about it and we
talk about cancel culture and then maybe
we organize a boycott most the time we
don't even do that but even if we do the
boycott
it lasts for like a week if it makes it
that long and it has no effect at all
doesn't matter
the company doesn't feel the pain at all
and then we just go back to normal go
back to using those products
and part of the reason that happens is
because
you know in a way it's like you almost
don't don't have a choice with some of
this stuff you have to buy things you
need razors you need you know you need
basic things like that
uh unless you're gonna go shave with a
butcher's knife or something you need
some kind of grooming product if you are
if you are going to shave at all which i
wouldn't recommend but if you do
so partly out of necessity we go back we
start using these products again which
is why the daily wire we've decided well
let's make our own products just like
we're making our own entertainment
rather than complaining that
entertainment is increasingly
ideologically
biased in the extreme
we'll make our own
know and if you want to
uh
make a statement
that's the way that you do it
if you want to more than making a
statement actually have a chance at
winning
winning the culture war that's how you
do it
we'll just do it ourselves make our own
products make our own things
and that's what we're doing well i hope
you enjoyed that clip from the matt wall
show if you did go ahead and hit that
subscribe button right down there so you
can stay up to date on all of our future
content